ich dachte mir einen tag nach dem tag
der deutschen einheit reden wir einmal
über die deutsche einheit und wie weit
wir da eigentlich gekommen sind bei
twitter hat man häufig das gefühl das
was uns am ehesten noch trend ist das
jägerschnitzel die einen mögen es lieber
mit ihrer petsos ich mag lieber die
paniert jagdwurst aber so einfach ist
das nicht so einfach ist es eben nicht
wenn man uns sich das anguckt einen
betagten beton und stahlbetonbauer
verdient im schnitt 300 euro weniger in
der ausbildung wenn er sie in
ostdeutschland macht als im westen und
wenn wir uns dann angucken dass wir noch
immer keine angeglichenen renten haben
haben wir große probleme in diesem land
glaublich und besonders auch meine
generation wir haben viel zu tun um
dorthin zu kommen ich glaube dass in den
16 jahren von angela merkels regierung
viel passiert ist für die für die
ehemaligen ostdeutschen für die
ehemalige ddr aber es gibt eben auch
immer noch viel zu tun deswegen glaube
ich 31 jahre nach der deutschen einheit
haben wir immer noch keine vollständige
einheit auch wenn ich mir das sehr
wünschen würde fühle mich trotzdem sehr
deutsch aber das ist auch ganz wichtig
hier zu sagen ich würde mich nicht immer
nur ostdeutsche auch wenn ich gerne
ostdeutschen will deswegen dieses thema
mitgebracht habe aber ich glaube dass es
nichts zu diskutieren wo rund um dazu
darüber zu reden wie wir dorthin kommen
können und was eigentlich noch so
passieren muss
dass sie sich deutsch fühlen ist sehr
verständlich ich komme auch aus
thüringen das ist das grüne herz
deutschlands immer gewesen wird es immer
sein so so weit sind wir uns einig ich
glaube dass es auf diese unterschiede
sie eben aufgezählt haben zwar auch
ankommt aber das wird selbst wenn sie
eingeebnet während rente löhne und so
weiter wird die probleme zwischen ost
und west überhaupt nicht beseitigen ich
glaube wir haben es da mit einer tief
eingegrabenen differenz zwischen ost und
westdeutschen zu tun die so tief
eingegraben ist wie die differenz
zwischen nord- und südstaaten in den usa
seit dem bürgerkrieg da gibt es gar
keinen grund mehr warum menschen sich
nord oder süd stadler risch fühlen
müssen es gibt keine sklaverei mehr und
so weiter aber das wird weiter
transportiert kulturell in der
erinnerung der menschen und in
ostdeutschland wird weiter transportiert
wie mit ihnen nach der einheit
umgesprungen worden ist was die treuhand
angerichtet hat die viele betriebe
vernichtet hat die hätten weiter
bestehen können wie sie das eigentum das
volkseigentum der ddr was eigentlich
allen menschen irgendwo einer gewissen
weise gehört hat verkauft hat und zwar
wohin nach westdeutschland oder ins
ausland das heißt die eigentumsquote in
ostdeutschland ist verschwindend gering
es gibt zwar auch ein sicherheits und
jährigen höher als im gesamtdurchschnitt
satz stimmt überhaupt nicht es gibt
einen sichern das stimmt leider nicht da
können wir noch einmal drüber ausnahme
es sind glaube ich 80 prozent des
volkseigentums damals die ddr sind
außerhalb deutschlands verkauft worden
es gibt einen sich entwickelnden
mittelstand aber das holt das nicht auf
was in was westdeutschland voraus liegt
ich glaube sogar dass wir aufhören
müssen uns ständig darüber den kopf zu
zerbrechen wie wir ost und westdeutsche
angleichen wir werden es nicht schaffen
die ostdeutschen müssen sie es war
umgekehrt gedanken machen wie sie ein
bisschen selbstständig werden innerhalb
dieses deutschland wie die länder sich
selbstständig machen wie die
ministerpräsidenten mal auf den tisch
hauen müssen einander an meine eigene
position vertreten mal sagen da machen
wir nicht mit oder fragen wo sind wir
eigentlich in eurem wahlkampf tauchen
wir darauf als ostdeutsche länder ich
habe keinen satz dazu gehört bei keiner
partei hat bei linken ja aber ansonsten
hat niemand was gesagt zu ostdeutschland
das gibt es gar nicht wir reden hier
über über mieterhöhungen in
westdeutschland über wohnungs und unsere
weiter in ostdeutschland ist die
situation genau umgekehrt da sind iks
häuser stehen leer müssen abgerissen
werden das interessiert im westen aber
überhaupt niemanden und da muss mal
schluss mit seien deshalb sage ich ihnen
these dagegen aus deutscher macht euch
selbst
ich habe dazu eine frage zu dem was sie
gesagt haben und zwar das thema
erinnerungen aber ist noch nicht an der
zeit und ich bin ja sowohl italienerin
als auch deutsche ich besitzt beide
staatsbürgerschaften ich bin in
deutschland aufgewachsen habe auch in
italien gelebt meine eltern sind
italiener und in italien leben wir den
nationalstolz sehr stark also sind stolz
auf unsere herkunft wir sind stolz auf
unser land und das ist ja grundsätzlich
ein punkt den ich in deutschland sehr
vermisse klar aufgrund der geschichte
aber ich sage auch und das ist dann das
thema mit den erinnerungen
es ist doch an der zeit dass man sich
auch ein stück weit von diesen
geschichten und von diesen erinnerungen
auslöst weil wir unsere generation
die jetzt hier aufgewachsen ist oder
hier aufwächst in deutschland die hat
damit ja gar nichts mehr zu tun
haben dass andere spieler glaube dass
meine generation sogar diese
erinnerungen hochhalten muss weil es
waren mutige ostdeutsche die damals vor
der wende auf die straßen gegangen um
die einigkeit zu erstreiten und genau
diese erinnerungen hoch zu halten halte
ich als große aufgabe für meine
generation das ist genauso wie es in
generationen überdauern wird dass wir
die erinnerung an die ns diktatur
irgendwie weiter ist man da nicht ein
umdenken in den köpfen der leute
hinbekommen dass man miteinander und
nicht immer noch
also ich hab ich habe ich habe zwei
sachen einmal habe ich es ein bisschen
auch versucht nachzuvollziehen warum das
so ist und dass es in ostdeutschland
dieses lohngefälle gibt und man stößt
immer auf erklärung weiß gar nicht ob
das stimmt einmal heißt es gibt es
weniger jobs für hochbezahlte in aus
deutschland das kommen weil weniger
forschungs und
entwicklungszentren da sind es gibt
natürlich die habs rund um volkswagen
und wir wissen dass eine katze jena und
sonstwo wo dann die die entsprechenden
abgebaut worden sind und es auch viel
forschung und entwicklung gibt aber
ansonsten
offenkundig so nicht so wird es
zumindest immer begründet geht es nicht
um produktivität ist das andere und dann
sagen die gewerkschaften ja das nicht
daran dass weniger leute dort
tatsächlich auch tarifgebunden arbeiten
nämlich weniger mehr als zehn prozent
weniger als im a lauf im westen besten
56 prozent 43 prozent so das sind ja
schon mal zwei sehr technische
erklärungen wo man auch abhilfe schaffen
könnte man könnte an der
tarifgebundenheit arbeiten und man
könnte sicherlich mit hilfe des staates
oder der landesregierung diese auf die
hinterbeine sie stellen müssten sagen
unternehmen verlagert mehr forschung und
entwicklung auch in unsere länder nicht
nur dann reichen nicht nur dass das
fängt ja das ist nicht nur eine
kulturelle sachen die benachteiligte
sonnen muss
einfach weitergehen ich hatte das in der
volkswirtschaftslehre auch und manchmal
ist die universität jedoch für etwas gut
auch wenn man böse es werde nicht so und
da waren es genau diese punkte plus ist
auch ein weiterer punkt warum manche
gebiete nächste schnell nach oben kommen
weil viele arbeitgeber auch keine höhere
qualifikation bezahlen wollen und bellas
punkte und alice punkt mit der
niedrigere produktivität pro stunde und
dann noch die anderen punkte ist der
standort muss ja einfach sexy wert ist
unternehmen hin zu gehen aber das ist
eigentlich ich finde die politik ich
finde das beispiel mit ost und west mit
dem lohngefälle zeigt eigentlich
komplett dass die wirtschaft der motor
unseres landes ist und die politik nur
rahmenbedingungen schaffen kann und die
politik hat sie jetzt schon versucht bei
der rente die angeglichen wird da wurde
ja schon viel unternommen den letzten
jahren aber ich glaube jahrzehnt aber
ich glaube dass wir ganz klar machen
müssen der osten muss als
industriestandort gewinnen und was weiß
ich auch noch oft gelesen habe ist dass
höherqualifizierte dann auch gerne aus
dem osten wegziehen halt in den westen
und ich glaube man muss einfachen wird
es muss man muss wahrscheinlich
wirtschaftsförderung betreiben das kann
die politik natürlich machen aber ich
glaube vor allem müssen firmen dort
ansehen ich finde der osten zeit
komplett und das ist natürlich auch
kulturell mit der übergangenen
planwirtschaft die ja da war lange zeit
zu erklären
ich finde der osten ist paradebeispiel
dafür dass die wirtschaften bessere
unternehmer ist als der start der
berühmtesten glaube ich dass das halt
nicht sexy ist ich hatte in meinem
mediencampus in mittweida und
da gab es außer der universität für
junge leute nicht wirklich viel was man
hätte ist mit weiter ich will nicht ins
all schießen ok eine stunde glaube ich
ganz viele wieder gegen bolt rallye
unterwegs glaube ich jedenfalls für
angehende ehrgeizige junge leute
unattraktiv und da hat ja leider recht
die die region mit der höchsten heim
gewehre quote in deutschland liegt gott
sei dank in thüringen also wir haben
auch viele die zurückkommen aber sie
gehen erst mal weg das ist ein problem
jetzt will ich mal den bogen schlagen so
jugendliche sagen ja es ist nicht ganz
schlecht nehmen dass wir
das hier im wahlkampf zu wenig wert
darauf gelegt haben was ostdeutsche
betrifft und der punkt ist das sind
häufig themen für den ländlichen raum
deutschen lassen sich in einer
preisklasse unterbuttern das ist nicht
mehr wichtig aber wenn man aber dann
einfach auf den punkt nach ende führte
unbedingt der punkt dass doch wir reden
nicht nur darüber dass sich forschung
bei uns ansiedeln muss sondern von 50
einrichtungen öffentlich rechtlichen
rundfunks genau eine nach ostdeutschland
geschafft ist der geschichte der kika
der bei uns in erfurt sitzt der einzige
der einrichtung da haben wir doch schon
grundproblem identifiziert an keiner
ostdeutschen universität ist die leitung
ostdeutschen auch das ist doch
eigentlich irre dass wir unsere eigenen
leute nicht einem unternehmen das in ost
großen unternehmen das in ostdeutschland
tätig ist ist ein ostdeutscher chef
das ist ja das kann man durch aber die
wirtschaftliche argumentation so richtig
die es will ja nicht widersprechen
reicht nicht richtig also wenn man sieht
dass ein ministerpräsident wie herr
haseloff in sachsen-anhalt der macht mal
in einem wahlkampf vorher ein paar
monate den rücken gerade und sagt man
ein paar abweichende töne zur
westdeutschen politik und schon hat ein
riesen wahlergebnis die leute in
ostdeutschland müssen mal stolz sein auf
einen ministerpräsident das waren sie
früher auf kurt biedenkopf und seit
dieser zeit wurde
in der anfangszeit ja der ist dann auch
eine gewisse tragischerweise abgegangen
aber jedenfalls das muss sein das muss
eine eine eine politik in ostdeutschland
erkennbar werden die ostdeutsche
interessen verfolge das kann nicht nur
auch die linkspartei soll noch mein
abschluss das wo sie in dieser partie
ministerpräsidenten und das haben sie ja
völlig zu recht gesagt dass die
ministerpräsidenten rücken gerade machen
und sagen so und jetzt sind wir genau da
müssen wir kommen aber und da muss ich
auch meine partei jetzt mein
verantwortung nimmt wir haben viel zu
tun gerade auch was die ost cdu angeht
und dazu braucht es auch einen konvent
wir machen auch die machen das braucht
werbeeinsatz noch jan ostdeutsche
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz wie vor
solchen verhandlungen die sie jetzt in
berlin laufen über die koalition eine
liste von forderungen aus deutschland
aufgestellt ja das muss im
koalitionsvertrag stehen
[Musik]